الصور مخيفة لأي شخص ، لكن
الحرب في أوكرانيا قد تسبب القلق وحتى
الخوف لدى الأطفال الصغار الذين يرون أو يسمعون
عن الاضطرابات عند التحدث معهم ،
اجعل الأمر مستقيمًا ، تقول
عالمة نفس الأطفال في كليفلاند كلينك فانيسا
جنسن إنه
بعيد وهذا شيء نما  -
يسمح الكبار للكبار
بالعناية بهذا الأمر في الوقت الحالي ، فنحن
نعتني بك
، وبعد ذلك سنتأكد من أن البالغين يعتنون
بذلك ، لذا في بعض الأحيان تحتاج فقط إلى تبسيط
الأمر ، يقول جنسن إنه يمكن للأطفال في أي عمر أن يكونوا
منزعجة مما يرونه ،
يمكن أن تظهر الصور في الكوابيس
والذعر الليلي ، تقول إنه من
الجيد مراقبة ما يراه الأطفال والحماية
من عرض الصور المزعجة
للأطفال الأصغر سنًا إذا رأى الطفل
شيئًا مزعجًا تقول جنسن إنها تطلب
الكثير من  أسئلة لقياس
ما يعرفونه وما يشعرون به إذا رأيت أشياء
أو سمعت أشياء
إما تتساءل عنها أو أنها
مجرد نوع من الرعب
الذي تعرفه دعنا نتحدث عنها لمساعدتهم على
تطبيع تلك الأشياء  الأفكار لا بأس أن
تشعر بالخوف من أن
هذا يحدث في عالمنا إذا كان
الطفل يشعر بعدم الأمان.تقول جنسن إنه
قد يساعد في إظهار أوكرانيا على خريطة
لهم حتى يروا القتال بعيدًا
بغض النظر عن عمر طفلك ، تقول كل
الأطفال  بحاجة إلى مزيد من الدعم
والطمأنينة من والديهم الآن
للدقيقة الصحية أنا ماندي جيثر